any other weekday paola amarozo would be
on shift making sure patrons don't
damage priceless works of art at a
museum in rome
instead she's had a protest against
italy's latest covet 19 restriction
to go to work it's now required for all
italians over the age of 50 to get their
covet 19 vaccine
something 61 year old amarozo refuses to
do
they're stealing my job part of my life
it's disoriented me the bills haven't
started arriving yet but when they do
what then
italy's latest covet 19 restriction took
effect on tuesday meaning around a half
million unvaccinated workers over 50 are
barred from going to work or receiving
sick pay
for months italy has increased
restrictions on the unvaccinated first
they were barred from restaurants and
other venues now their very livelihoods
and income are at risk for refusing the
jab
i am not anti-vaxx but i support the
freedom to choose everyone should be
able to decide for themselves whether to
take the vaccine or not if someone
decides not to they shouldn't go hungry
taking their job away
although italy has a nearly 90
vaccination rate the government says
it's necessary to encourage as many
people in higher risk age groups to get
the jab
those opposed to the measure say this
latest restriction is an abuse of state
power that it takes away a fundamental
right from the individual the choice of
what to put in their body
it's simply a threat it's the same thing
the mafia does the mafia tells you if
you don't obey i'm going to make your
life impossible and the government says
if you don't give me access to your body
we'll make your life impossible
medical experts like dr patricia
laurenti disagree lost
the government has given us a tool for
protection in a pandemic this is
necessary this isn't a normal time these
haven't been normal times for the past
two years this tough choice is necessary
a tough choice to get their shots that
hundreds of thousands of workers are
still unwilling to make no matter the
high cost adam rainey al jazeera rome